Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. The winter energy crisis won't be as bad as everybody fears. Inflation will start to come down.
感谢您收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、系列节目的抢先收听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。若想收听加更节目、抢先收听、无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您在使用 Apple Podcasts 应用，只需轻点几下即可在应用内订阅。冬天的能源危机不会像大家担心的那么严重。通货膨胀将开始下降。
By the spring, that enormous Labour poll lead will be a fading memory. And as the next election approaches, ordinary people across the land will throw their caps in the air and cheer the name of good queen liz no no i can't do it tempting as it is to tilt against the conventional wisdom sometimes you just have to face facts the conference was awful the speech was awful this has been the worst start to any premiership i think in recent history, perhaps even in all British history. That, Dominic Sambrook, was a top pundit, a top columnist, a top historian, namely yourself, delivering your verdict on Liz Truss. What was that, about a couple of weeks ago?
到春天，工党在民调中那巨大的领先优势将成为遥远的记忆。随着下次大选临近，全国的普通百姓将把帽子抛向空中，为伟大的丽兹女王欢呼……不，不，我做不到。尽管逆流而上、对抗传统智慧很有诱惑力，但有时你不得不面对现实：大会糟透了，演讲糟透了，我认为这是近代史上，甚至可能是整个英国历史上任何一任首相最糟糕的开局。多米尼克·桑布鲁克，那是顶级名嘴、顶级专栏作家、顶级历史学家——也就是你自己——对利兹·特拉斯做出的评价。那是大概几个星期前的事吧？
Yes, it was. So halfway through her premiership. Yeah. So now it's come to pass. So we're recording this at 1340, so 10 minutes after Liz Truss announced her resignation. And clearly people across the land will not be throwing their caps in the air and cheering the name of good Queen Liz. And would you, I guess nothing has happened since you wrote that to change your opinion that she ranks as perhaps the worst. I mean, seriously, do you think she's the worst prime minister of all time? Well, I'll tell you what I wrote. I wrote later on in the article. I think she's comfortably, putting aside her politics, I said, I think
是的，没错。是在她任期的中途。对。所以现在这一切都应验了。我们录制这期节目的时间是13点40分，也就是利兹·特拉斯宣布辞职后10分钟。很显然，全国上下的人民不会把帽子抛向空中，为伟大的丽兹女王欢呼。我想，自从你写下那篇文章以来，没有任何事情发生能改变你的看法——即她或许是有史以来最糟糕的首相。我的意思是，说真的，你认为她是史上最糟糕的首相吗？好吧，我告诉你我写了什么。我在文章后面写道。抛开她的政治立场不谈，我认为她……
she's comfortably the least impressive person to become prime minister in my lifetime since the advent of universal suffrage, and perhaps even since the advent of universal suffrage and perhaps even since the creation of the office under george i and actually i think uh as a columnist you spend an awful lot of time making historical parallels and and getting basically getting things wrong making well and engaging in hyperbole as well right yes i mean the worst the best whatever yes but making predictions that turn out to be ludicrously untrue however in this case i think it was pretty obvious to anybody who without a stake in the contest as it were the liz trust was a fantastically underpowered candidate
在我的有生之年，自从普选制出现以来，她无疑是成为首相的最缺乏 impressing（令人印象深刻）气质的人，甚至可能自乔治一世设立首相职位以来，以及实际上，作为一个专栏作家，你会花大量时间去做历史平行对比，然后——基本上就是把事情搞砸，做出错误的预测，并沉迷于夸大其词，对吧？是的。我的意思是，最糟糕的、最好的、随便什么，是的。但是做出事后被证明荒谬错误的预测。然而在这种情况下，我认为对于任何在竞选中没有利益相关的人来说，利兹·特拉斯是一个能力严重不足的候选人，这实在是太显而易见了。
um uh for the tory leadership she won all the. There was nothing in her premiership that suggested any sort of hitherto concealed qualities. It seems to me to have been one last massive gesture of irresponsibility and spite from the preceding Prime Minister, who politically was much more aligned with Sunak. I mean, Sunak was continuity Boris. But because Johnson resented what Sunak had done to him, he was determined to spike his guns no matter what he could. And so he backed Truss, presumably knowing she'd be terrible. Well, that's what people say, isn't it? Putting his kind of personal resentment above the national good.
呃，对于托利党党魁来说，她赢得所有的……在她的任期内，没有任何迹象表明她有任何迄今为止被掩盖的品质。在我看来，这是前任首相发出的最后一次大规模不负责任且恶意的举动，从政治上看，这位前首相与苏纳克的立场要契合得多。我的意思是，苏纳克是鲍里斯的延续。但由于约翰逊对苏纳克对他的所作所为心存怨恨，他决心不惜一切代价给苏纳克使绊子。所以他支持了特拉斯，大概是知道她会糟糕透顶。好吧，人们就是这么说的，对吧？把那种个人怨恨置于国家利益之上。
Yes. I mean, that's what some people say that uh boris johnson i mean it seems unbelievable to me that if just a few months ago you and i were recording another emergency podcast or he recorded i think two emergency podcasts on the fall of boris johnson once when he had a confidence vote which he narrowly survived and then once when he had that absolutely preposterous series of events in number 10, where everybody resigned, but he refused to leave. Now at that stage, I can remember we did this podcast and we said, and you said to me, is there any precedent for this in British political history? And the answer was no. And I said to you at the time, I don't think, you know, I never
是的。我是说，有些人就是这么说的，呃，鲍里斯·约翰逊——对我来说，这似乎令人难以置信：就在几个月前，你和我还在录制另一期紧急播客，或者他录制了，我想是两期关于鲍里斯·约翰逊倒台的紧急播客，一次是他在险些过关的信任投票之后，另一次是他在唐宁街发生了那场绝对荒谬的事件之后——所有人（内阁成员）都辞职了，但他拒绝离开。现在在那个阶段，我记得我们做过这个播客，我们说过，你对我说，英国政治史上有过先例吗？答案是没有。我当时对你说，我想，你知道，我从未
imagined I would see scenes of this sort of utter ridiculousness in number 10 well and yet they have been eclipsed by yesterday's laughable so for our overseas listeners a laughable shambles in westminster when the itv evening news reported on it and the you know the sort of the very neutral sober kind of news presenter, Tom Bradbury, said, it is total and utter abject chaos. And that was his introduction to the main news bulletin. That gave you some sense of the flavour. You had government whips effing and blinding, storming out. Truss apparently pursuing her chief whip around the Palace of Westminster, begging her to stay.
想象过自己会看到唐宁街出现这种彻底荒谬的场景。好吧，然而它们已经被昨天威斯敏斯特那场滑稽的——对于我们的海外听众来说，威斯敏斯特那场滑稽的混乱——给彻底掩盖了。当ITV晚间新闻对此进行报道时，那个——你知道的——非常中立、冷静的新闻主播汤姆·布拉德比说：“这是彻底、完全、绝对的一团糟。”那是他对主要新闻快讯的开场白。这让你对当时的氛围有了一些概念。你会看到政府党鞭们口吐芬芳、气急败坏地摔门而出。特拉斯显然在威斯敏斯特宫到处追着她的首席党鞭，哀求她留下来。
Home secretary forced to resign all kinds of stuff anyway but dominic we're not a politics podcast because i gather that there is another politics i'm not aware of another podcast in the goldhanger stable yeah that that may well be handling this um so i thought that since we are uh history focused um there might be two areas to focus on. One is parallels in British history, short-lived prime ministers, short term. Are there other parallels in other periods, other countries that we could compare this to? And then the other question that I would like to ask you is that you are a historian of modern Britain. You've written this series of
内政大臣被迫辞职，各种乱七八糟的事……不管怎样，多米尼克，我们不是一个政治播客，因为我听说高杭（Goldhanger）大本营里还有另一个政治——我不知道有另一个播客，是的，那可能正在处理这个，呃……所以我想，既然我们是专注于历史的，或许可以聚焦于两个方面。一是英国历史上的平行事件，比如短命的首相、短暂的任期。是否有其他时期、其他国家的其他平行事件可以拿来作比较？然后我想问你的另一个问题是，你是一位现代英国历史学家。你写过这一系列
brilliant analyses of British political, but also social and cultural life from what, 1955, is it? Yeah, 1956, up to 1982. And one of the running themes in your books is that most people do not pay much attention to what is going on in Downing Street. So they're busy whipping up Angel Delight or playing on Space Hoppers or watching football or whatever. So I would like to ask you, does all this matter or is it just surface froth? But first of all, short-lived prime ministers. So Liz Truss, by the conventional reckoning, has now beaten George Canning. Yes, yes, she has beaten George Canning. George Canning, who we last mentioned accompanying Horatio Nelson.
对英国政治、社会以及文化生活进行精彩分析的著作，时间跨度是从什么时期开始的，1955年吗？是的，从1956年一直到1982年。你书中的一个贯穿主题是，大多数人其实并不怎么关注唐宁街正在发生的事情。他们正忙着搅拌“天使之乐”甜品（Angel Delight）、玩太空跳跳球（Space Hopper）、看足球或做别的什么。所以我想问你，这一切真的很重要，还是仅仅是表面的泡沫？但首先，关于短命的首相。所以，按照传统算法，利兹·特拉斯现在已经超过了乔治·卡宁。是的，是的，她已经超过了乔治·卡宁。我们上一次提到乔治·卡宁，还是他在1805年陪同霍雷肖·纳尔逊。
Oh God, yes. To HMS Victory in Portsmouth in 1805, shortly before he sails off to go and die at the Battle of Trafalgar. So that's the measure of just what a long running record that's been. There is some controversy, isn't there, about whether the Earl of Bath should actually hold the honour. So he was asked in 1746 to form a ministry and he went away and two days later came back and said he couldn't. So by that reckoning, he would still hold the record. Yes. Most sources don't rank him as a prime minister. He's not in any of the official lists.
哦天哪，是的。前往朴次茅斯的“胜利号”战舰，不久之后纳尔逊就扬帆出海并在特拉法尔加战役中阵亡。所以这就是这个长期保持的纪录的分量。关于巴斯伯爵是否应该实际拥有这个荣誉，存在一些争议，不是吗？因此，他在1746年被邀请组阁，他离开后两天又回来，说他组阁失败了。所以按这个算法，他将仍然保持这个纪录。是的。大多数消息来源并不把他列为首相。他不在任何官方名单上。
I think asking somebody to be a prime minister and then them coming back two days later and saying i can't be doesn't that seems to me a far frankly a far more dignified way of proceeding than somebody becoming prime minister and then 45 days later saying i can't i'm everybody hates me and i'm terrible i have to go i mean don't just on the human level it's kind kind of, it's the worst nightmare, isn't it? Applying for the job for which you're not, not ultimately qualified. You get it. And then your, your inability to, to hold this job that you've wanted all your life is on the most humiliating public stage. Tom, I, I wrote a column about this earlier this week in relation to Kwasi Kwarteng, Truss's short-lived chancellor, about nightmares. And I said, because I wrote about how I'd had a nightmare about being pursued by Kwasi Kwarteng and then about having to enter a poetry competition against him.
我认为，邀请某人担任首相，然后他们两天后回来拒绝说“我当不了”，在我看来，坦率地说，这比某人在当上首相45天后说“我当不了，每个人都讨厌我，我太糟糕了，我必须离开”要体面得多，不是吗？我的终极意思是，仅仅从人性的层面来看，这简直是一种噩梦，不是吗？申请了一份你最终并不胜任的工作。你得到了它。然后你无力掌控这份你梦寐以求了一辈子的工作，却被暴露在最具羞辱性的公众舞台上。汤姆，我本周早些时候就此写过一篇专栏，是关于夸西·克沃滕（特拉斯那个短命的财政大臣）的，主题就是噩梦。我说过，因为我写到自己曾做过噩梦，梦见被夸西·克沃滕追赶，然后梦见不得不跟他进行一场诗歌比赛。
So I had two successive nightmares about Kwasi. This is when you had flu, wasn't it? I had flu. Yeah, we should explain. You don't normally have that such weird nightmares yeah um so i had two i and i and i i wrote the piece and it was all about politicians uh and the sort of the nightmare that we all have of being found out sort of imposter syndrome and i i do think that would trust that actually never before in british history has there been such a spectacular case of somebody getting a job for which they are utterly unqualified and then imploding so dramatically in front of the cameras. moment when she was you know she she was completely humiliated uh kwateng her chancellor and sort of
所以我连续做了两个关于夸西的噩梦。这是在你得流感的时候发生的，对吧？我得了流感。是的，我们应该解释一下。你平时不会做这么奇怪的噩梦。是的，呃……所以我做了两个，我——我——我写了那篇文章，全部关于政客们，以及我们所有人都有的那种被识破的噩梦——也就是所谓的“冒名顶替综合征”。我确实认为，对于特拉斯而言，英国历史上从来没有过这样一个轰动性的案例：某人得到了一份她完全不胜任的工作，然后居然在镜头前以如此戏剧性的方式彻底崩塌。当她——你知道的——她彻底受辱的那一刻，夸西·克沃滕——她的财政大臣兼犯罪同伙——不得不走人。她赶走了他，迎来了杰里米·亨特——这位“明白人先生”来当她的财政大臣，并在她面前撕毁了她的政策。我记得看到她坐在下议院的前排长椅上，和亨特并肩而坐，她看起来——人们甚至说，她就像是从杜莎夫人蜡像馆被放出来放风20分钟一样。你知道，她看起来——
partner in crime had to go she got rid of him in came jeremy hunt sort of mr sensible to be her chancellor and to rip up her policy in front of her and i remember seeing her sitting on the front bench of the house in the house of commons alongside hunt and she looked like i mean people sort of said she's on 20 minute day release from madam to swords you know she looked like, I mean, people sort of said, she's on 20-minute day release from Madam to Swords. You know, she looked like somebody in shock, the colour drained from her cheeks. And there is, at a human level, I mean, personally, I don't have a tremendous amount of sympathy with Liz Truss.
人们甚至说，她就像是从杜莎夫人蜡像馆被放出来放风20分钟一样。你知道，她看起来就像是一个处于休克状态的人，面色苍白。从人性的角度来看，我的意思是，就个人而言，我对利兹·特拉斯并没有太多的同情。
No one forced her to go for the premiership. But you're right. It must be, I mean, it's a bit like the podcast we did about Nixon and Watergate. To see your career unravel in such a humiliating way in public, your inadequacies, we all fear we've got them and we all know our own limitations. But to have them laid bare so extensively in front of an audience of tens of millions, that must be awful. Also, I mean, the thing with Kuateng is that they're very good friends. I mean, whether they still are, I don't know.
没有人强迫她去竞选首相。但你是对的。这一定——我的意思是，这有点像我们之前做的关于尼克松和水门事件的播客。看到你的政治生涯在公众面前以如此羞辱的方式土崩瓦解，你所有的无能——我们都害怕自己有这些缺点，也都清楚自己的局限性——但却将它们赤裸裸地暴露在数千万观众面前，那一定糟透了。而且，我的意思是，关于克沃滕的事是，他们是非常好的朋友。我的意思是，他们现在是不是还是，我不知道。
But they were absolutely, you know, they wrote the budget, which helped precipitate this meltdown together. And the figure of a supposedly powerful officeholder obliged to defenestrate a favourite. I mean, it's kind of redolent of medieval or early modern history. I mean, the king's favourites being – so it's a bit like – I mean, faint echoes perhaps of Charles I being – And the Earl of Stratford. So quasi-quasi-ing is the Earl of Stratford.
但他们绝对是——你知道的，他们共同编写了导致这场经济大崩盘的预算案。而一个本应大权在握的官员却被迫公开抛弃（defenestrate）自己最器重的人，这种形象——有点让人联想到中世纪或近代早期历史。我的意思是，国王的心腹们被——所以这有点像——也许是对查理一世被——以及斯特拉福德伯爵（Earl of Strafford）的微弱回响。所以，夸西·克沃滕就是斯特拉福德伯爵。
Yes, or Edward II. Edward II being forced to getl of strafford so quasi-quarting is the earl of strafford yes or um edward ii edward ii being forced to get rid of um you know his favorites or whatever henry viii when after he got rid of thomas cromwell years afterwards he would basically sort of say if only cromwell was here he would know how to handle this yes but henry viii i mean nobody ever forced henry viii to do anything i mean No, that's right. Whereas the thing about Charles I and Edward II are humiliated, and they're broken reeds after that. I mean, it's one of the things that actually leads Charles to fight the Civil War. But someone like Edward II, after he is forced to get rid of his favourites,
是的，或者爱德华二世。爱德华二世被迫罢免了斯特拉福德伯爵——所以夸西·克沃滕就是斯特拉福德伯爵。是的，或者……爱德华二世。爱德华二世被迫罢免了——你知道的——他的心腹之臣之类的人。亨利八世在多年后除掉托马斯·克伦威尔之后，基本上会说：“要是克伦威尔还在就好了，他会知道怎么处理这个。”是的，但亨利八世——我的意思是，从来没有人能强迫亨利八世做任何事。我的意思是——不，那是真的。然而关于查理一世和爱德华二世，他们受到了羞辱，此后便成了残破的芦苇。我的意思是，这也是导致查理一世挑起内战的原因之一。但像爱德华二世，在他被迫罢免了心腹之后，
his authority gets shredded and shredded and shredded. Yeah, and that's certainly the case for truss i mean and and and if this truss is feeling bad i mean she can always reflect on the fate of edward ii and think that it that it might be worse yes i suppose i suppose so well anyway tom to return to your question you asked me which is about um precedence so we were talking about george canning uh canning's excuse for being a very short-lived prime minister is that he was 119 days, is that he had TB. Yeah, that's fair enough, isn't it? You know, most very, very short-lived prime ministers, I'm looking at the list here.
他的权威被一次又一次地粉碎、削弱。是的，特拉斯的情况绝对也是如此。而且，如果利兹·特拉斯现在感觉很糟糕，嗯，她随时可以反思一下爱德华二世的命运，并认为事情可能还会更糟。是的，我想，我想是的。无论如何，汤姆，回到你的问题，你问我关于——呃——先例的事。所以我们刚才在谈论乔治·卡宁。卡宁作为一名极其短命的首相，他的借口是他在任119天是因为他得了结核病。是的，这还算合情合理，不是吗？你知道，大多数非常非常短命的首相——我正在看这里的名单。
So Bonalor, for example, who was the 20th century's shortest-lived prime minister, Andrew Bonalor, so that's the 1920s. He came and went in 1922, but he had throat cancer. And he had a fairly distinguished record as the leader of the Tory party for many years before that. And he'd been involved in the coalition government in the Great War and so on. So Truss is really out on her own. Since the dawn of universal suffrage there has never been the case a case where somebody has become prime minister through an internal kind of party leadership election and then disappeared within such a short period of time and it's been accelerating hasn't it the pace at which prime ministers come and go yeah um but somebody had tweeted that they have a four-month
比如博纳·劳，他是20世纪任期最短的首相，安德鲁·博纳·劳，那是20世纪20年代。他在1922年上台又下台，但他患有喉癌。在此之前，他作为保守党领袖有着相当杰出的履历多年，并且他曾参与第一次世界大战期间的联合政府等等。所以特拉斯真的是独树一帜。自普选制诞生以来，从来没有出现过这样一种情况：某人通过党内领袖选举成为首相，然后在如此短的时间内就消失了。这种首相来来去去的节奏一直在加快，不是吗？是的，呃……但有人在推特上说，他们有一个四个月大的婴儿，这个婴儿可能已经见证了两位、现在是三位首相，两位君主，大约20位财政大臣，大约50位内政大臣。我的意思是，这种人事更迭和节奏是我们作为一个国家所不习惯的。
year old baby who has witnessed two, now three prime ministers probably, two monarchs, about 20 chancellors of the Exchequer, about 50 Home Secretaries. I mean, the churn and the pace is something that we, as a nation, are not used to. No, and a good example of that, Tom, is our producer was just saying that Tony, that until the age of 38, I think he'd only ever seen three prime ministers. And in my case, from the moment I, let me get this right, from the autumn after I entered school until I think my 16th birthday, just after my 16th birthday, I'd only ever known one prime minister, and that was Margaret Thatcher.
是的，一个很好的例子，汤姆，我们的制作人刚刚说，托尼（Tony）直到38岁时，我想他只见过三位首相。而就我而言，从我——让我算算——从我上学后的那个秋天开始，直到我想是我的16岁生日，刚过完16岁生日的那段时间，我只经历过一位首相，那就是玛格丽特·撒切尔。我的意思是，她执政了那么久。然后，当然，约翰·梅杰执政了七年。接着托尼·布莱尔又执政了，大概是多少年，十年左右。所以，这在英国是非常少见的。
I mean, she was there so long. And then, of course, John Major was there for seven years. Tony Blair was then in for another, what was that, a decade or so. So, you know, it's very unusual in British. Yeah, so things are speeding up. And the peril that leaps out at me is the third century in the Roman Empire. It's where you have these long reigns in the second century, Hadrian and Marcus Aurelius and so on.
是的，所以事情正在加速。而让我眼前一亮的危机是罗马帝国的第三世纪。在那个世纪里，第二世纪那些长期统治的皇帝——哈德良、马可·奥勒留等等——之后，一切都在第三世纪土崩瓦解。而与利兹·特拉斯最明显的对比就是戈尔迪安一世（Gordian I）。这不是我经常从国内名嘴那里听到的对比。与利兹·特拉斯最明显的对比就是戈尔迪安一世。这不是我经常从国内名嘴那里听到的对比。所以，巴尔干半岛上有一个可怕的人物，马克西米努斯·色雷克斯（Maximinus Thrax），色雷克斯人马克西米努斯，他谋杀了合法皇帝，而这个合法皇帝与马可·奥勒留通过收养等方式有某种亲缘关系。
And then it all implodes in the third century. And the obvious comparison to Liz Truss is Gordian I. That's not a comparison I've often heard from the nation's pundits. The obvious comparison to Liz Truss is Gordian I. That's not a comparison I've often heard from the nation's pundits. So there's this terrifying figure up in the Balkans, Maximinus Thrax, Maximinus the Thracian, who's murdered the legitimate emperor, who is kind of related by adoption and so on, to Marcus Aurelius.
所以从这个意义上说，他与安东尼王朝的黄金时代有着某种联系。马克西米努斯·色雷克斯身高大约九英尺。他喜欢徒手把公牛的头扯下来取乐。据说他把妻子的手镯当作戒指戴在自己粗大的手指上。所以他是个挺吓人的人物。罗马的民众心想，我们可不想要这个野蛮人当我们的皇帝。于是他们求助于一位非常、非常杰出的参议员，名叫戈尔迪安，我想他当时大约80岁了。他们说：“去吧。”
So in that sense, a kind of link with the golden age of the Antonines. And Maximilian Serax is about nine foot. He kind of pulls the heads off oxen for fun. He's said to have worn his wife's bangles as rings on his enormous fingers. So he's a kind of terrifying guy. And people back in Rome, they think we don't want this barbarian as our emperor. And so they appeal to a very, very distinguished senator called Gordian, who I think is about 80. And they say, go on.
他其实一点也不想去，但他觉得这是自己的责任。他在统治非洲，所以他在迦太基。而且他老态龙钟，有点像拜登式的风格，他说：“没有我儿子，我应付不了这事。”于是他的儿子也成了——他儿子也叫戈尔迪安。所以戈尔迪安一世、戈尔迪安二世，他们有点像共治皇帝，呃……他们只坚持了22天，然后就完了。那是有人杀死了他们吗？是的，呃……戈尔迪安二世在迦太基城外输了一场战役，他在战斗中阵亡，尸体从未被找到。这个消息传到了戈尔迪安一世耳中——
And he really doesn't want to do it, but he feels it's his duty. He's governing Africa, so he's in Carthage. And he's so old, he's kind of Biden-esque, that he says, I can't manage this without my son. So his son becomes, he was also called Gordian. So Gordian I, Gordian II, they're kind of co-emperors um and they last 22 days and that's it that was someone kill them yeah they uh gordian the second loses a battle outside carthage um he gets killed in the battle his body's never found uh the news is
所以，与其召开新闻发布会并宣布辞职，他选择上吊自尽。噢天哪，这反应真够激烈的。所以，再次重申，我只是——你知道的，这可以说是历史的慰藉之一吧，是的，那就是无论情况对你来说看起来多糟，你都不是戈尔迪安一世，总有人处境更糟。所以，我只是把这一点献给利兹·特拉斯的支持者们，你知道的，情况可能会更糟。利兹·特拉斯将不会——汤姆，对于利兹·特拉斯的辞职荣誉名单来说，不会有很多候选人。所以如果你现在就带着你的安慰奖去申请的话，是的，那会挺好的。我觉得你其实有挺不错的机会。好吧，我把这记入官方记录。
brought to gordian the first so rather than hold a press conference and announce his resignation um he hangs himself oh my word that's that's a strong reaction so again again i'm just you know it's kind of one of the constellations of history i guess yeah it's that no matter how bad things may seem for you you're not gordon the first there are always people who've had it worse so i i'm just offering that uh supporters of liz trust that you know it could be worse liz trust will not there won't be many candidates tom for liz trust's um resignation honors list so if you get in now with your consolation yes that'd be good i'd say you've got a pretty good chance actually well i'm putting that on
当然，另一个平行事件是我们此前在澳大利亚首相系列节目中涉及过的内容。当时澳大利亚的首相们基本上每隔几周就会互相背刺捅刀子，不是吗？是的，他们确实如此。是的，我们当时在讨论这种领导层不断更迭的文化。我的意思是，那真的很荒谬，因为澳大利亚实际上并没有什么真正的大问题，我会这么说。
the record uh of course the other parallel is one that we have touched on within our series on Australian prime ministers. And there was a stage where basically prime ministers in Australia were knifing each other kind of every other week, weren't they? Yeah, they were. And yes, and we were talking about that, that culture of leadership spills. I mean, that was really, because there's actually nothing really wrong with Australia, I would say.
我的意思是，并不是说澳大利亚没有问题和挑战。它当然有。但如果你在寻找一个政治文化已经出现严重问题的国家，澳大利亚是不会排在那个名单的前列的。然而在那里，这确实——它变成了一种背刺文化，不是吗，还有那种荒谬的阴谋诡计。好吧，因为，是的，一个人被捅了刀子，然后他们又“死而复生”，去捅那个曾经捅过他们的人，事情就这样循环往复。所以这实际上成了一个应该让“死刑”作为一种武器回归的论据。这就是公元三世纪给我们的教训，是的。
I mean, it's not that Australia doesn't have issues and challenges. Of course it does. But I don't think if you were looking for a country where that political culture had gone wrong, Australia would not be high on that list. And there it was really – it became a sort of culture of backstabbing, didn't it, and a sort of ludicrous plotting. Well, because, yes, someone would be stabbed then they come back from the dead and stab the person who stabbed them and so it would go on so it was actually an argument for the return
还有其他让人联想到的平行事件吗？我想到了意大利。意大利，经济学人杂志的封面是布列塔尼娅（不列颠女神）手持三叉戟，上面缠绕着意大利面。意大利读者一定觉得这非常讨人喜欢。但在那里，你曾有过这样的首相——我的意思是，意大利或者两次世界大战之间的法国——首相们上台、下台，在几周或几天内消失。那里的不同之处在于，我认为，首先，首相们会倒台，因为那个政治体系的性质意味着政治是一场不断变化的组阁游戏。因此，随着不同的派系失去权力。
of death as a as a weapon again that's the lesson of the third century a.d yeah any other parallels that leap to mind i suppose italy there Italy, the cover of The Economist has Britannia holding her trident and it's got spaghetti wrapped around it. Italian readers must find that very flattering. But there you had prime ministers, I mean, Italy or in sort of France between the wars, you would have prime ministers rising and falling and disappearing within weeks or days. The difference there, I think, is that first of all, prime ministers would fall because the nature of that political system meant that politics was a constantly shifting exercise in coalition building. So as different factions fell from office.
这也是那些支持英国现行“多数代表制（first-past-post）”系统的人一直以来的观点。他们的论点总是：你不需要这种伴随着联合政府碎片化风险的混乱妥协，而你在比例代表制（PR）系统下就会遇到这种风险。但我想对此的反驳是，即使在我们这样的议会制系统里，两大政党本身也都是联合政府。它们确实是。但我们经历如此多动荡的原因，不仅仅是因为保守党是一个庞大的政治联盟。而是因为，我认为——保守党是一个庞大的政治联盟。而是因为，
And so that has always been the people in favour of the first-past-the-post system that we have in Britain. It's always that you don't need these kind of messy compromises with the risks of coalitions fragmenting, that you get in systems under proportional representation. But I suppose the comeback to that is that even in the parliamentary system like we have, both parties are coalitions. They are. But the reason we've had so much turmoil is not just that the Conservative Party is a very large coalition. It's that, I mean, I think it's conservative party is a very large coalition. It's that,
我的意思是，我认为这是几件事情共同作用的结果。好吧。好吧。等等，多米尼克。等等。等等。
I mean, I think it's the result of a couple of things. Okay. Okay. Hold on, Dominic. Hold on. Hold on.
等等。哦，悬念。这只是一集非常简短的游击式播客。我认为前半部分我们已经聊得差不多了。不过当我们回来时，我想回到我之前对你提出的那个问题，那就是：
Hold on. Oh, cliffhanger. So just a very kind of short guerrilla episode. And I think we've done enough for the first half. When we come back though, I want to return to that question I said to you, which was,
这一切真的重要吗？这究竟只是表面的浮沫，还是某种更深层的潜在结构性、宪政性、经济性痼疾的表现？我们拭目以待。我只想对你这么说：中场休息过后，这将是你在本播客历史上唯一一次模仿利兹·特拉斯的机会。所以汤姆·霍兰德是否会抓住这个机会，我们稍后揭晓。加入我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场活动门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
does any of this matter? Is it just surface for off or is it expressive of some deeper underlying structural constitutional economic malaise? We will find out. I'm just going to say this to you, that after the break will be your only opportunity in the history of this podcast to do an impersonation of Liz Truss. So whether or not Tom Holland takes that opportunity, we will discover in just a our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest of History, a special episode that we're putting out following the defenestration of yet another British Prime Minister, in this case, Liz Truss. And before the break, Dominic, you issued a challenge that I should do an impression of Liz Truss, which I'm going to turn down for the reason, basically for the reason that
大家好，欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》，这是一期特别节目，我们在又一位英国首相——这次是利兹·特拉斯——被公开抛弃后推出。中场休息前，多米尼克，你向我发出了挑战，要我模仿利兹·特拉斯。我决定拒绝这个挑战，原因很简单——基本上是因为我过去几周离开得太频繁了。你从来没听过她说话。所以整个夏天，我都忙于我的新书，我可能提到过。然后我去度假放松。作为放松的一部分，我不听新闻，也没有跟进时事。所以我回来后，错过了所有关于利兹·特拉斯的狗血剧情。然后过去几天我又不在。所以基本上，我真的不知道她说话是什么声音。这就是问题所在。她的声音听起来有点平，对吧？
I've been away so much over the past few weeks. You have never heard her speak. So all summer, I was flat out with my book, which I may have mentioned. Then I went away on holiday to decompress. And as part of that decompression, I was not listening to the news and I was not keeping up with it. And so I kind of came back and I missed all the Liz Truss drama. Then I was away again over the past few days. So basically, I don't really know what she sounds like. So that's the problem. She's got a kind of flat voice, hasn't she?
声音非常、非常平。我唯一能想象她说的话，就是那篇糟糕透顶、令人匪夷所思的糟糕演讲：“下周，我将在北京开设新的猪肉市场。”是的，我们进口的奶酪超过了一半以上。这简直是耻辱。好吧，这非常棒。我觉得利兹·特拉斯就坐在Zoom视频通话的另一端。太可怕了。这是你永远不想听到的一句话，汤姆。但是，除非她要给我一个贵族爵位。那个爵位。
Very, very flat voice the only thing i can really imagine her saying is is that awful awful speech incomprehensibly bad um next week i'll be in beijing opening up new pork markets yes we import more than half of all of our cheese. That is a disgrace. Well, that's very good. I feel that Liz Truss is at the other end of the Zoom call. That's terrifying. That's a sentence you never want to hear, Tom. But, well, unless she's offering me a peerage. That peerage.
以戈尔迪安为主题的安慰奖。那个爵位。那个爵位。以戈尔迪安为主题的安慰奖。是的，完全正确。那种情况下，我很乐意接受。但让我们回到那个问题：作为现代英国历史学家，这是一个典型的危机吗？这是那种表面的动荡吗？还是——你曾说过她是你能想到的最糟糕的首相——这是那种表面的动荡，还是某种——你曾说过她是你能想到的最糟糕的首相——这是最糟糕的危机吗？不，这不是最糟糕的危机。我认为这很糟糕，但不是最糟糕的危机。
The Gordian-themed consolation. That peerage. That peerage. The Gordian-themed consolation. Yeah, exactly. In which case, I'd love it. But let's get back to the question of, is this – so as a historian of modern Britain, is this a typical crisis? Is this the kind of surface churn? Or is this – you know, you said that she's the worst prime minister that you can think of. Is this the kind of surface churn or is this some you know you said that she's the worst prime minister that you can think of is this the worst crisis no it's not the worst crisis i think it's
那么，什么是最糟糕的危机？好吧，我想你不得不——这是一个无聊且陈词滥调的答案，但是——你不得不说1940年的夏天是最糟糕的危机。我的意思是，那是一场生存危机。战后时期——哦，战后时期，这真的很糟糕，对吧？我的意思是——你知道的，我不是指什么5088年或者别的什么时期——你知道的，从50年代后期一直到——直到今天，呃——这是一个非常棒的问题，汤姆。因为实际上，这取决于你如何看待——它切中了你如何看待政治的核心：你认为政治是国民生活和历史变迁等的驱动力呢，
bad but it's not the worst crisis so what's the worst crisis well i suppose you would have to i mean it's a boring and cliched answer but um you'd have to say the summer of 1940 is the worst crisis i mean that's an existential crisis post-war so oh post-war it's it's really bad yeah what i mean you know i'm not saying you know 5088 or whatever the period that you know so from from the late 50s through to through through to the present day um it's it's a it's a it's a brilliant question tom because actually it depends what how you well it cuts to the heart of how you think about politics do you think politics is the driver of national life and of historical change and so on um or do you think politics is the reflection of it?
还是认为政治是其反射？而你更倾向于后者，对吧？我更倾向于后者，是的。当我回想起20世纪70年代的危机时，例如，70年代有一些可怕的危机。我想两个最典型的例子是73至74年的冬天，当时实行每周三天工作制，各种进入紧急状态，泰达·希思（Ted Heath）的首相任期在石油危机后崩塌。然后我想是78至79年的“不满的冬天”（Winter of Discontent），当时詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）的首相任期几乎因为政府与工会关系的彻底破裂以及大规模罢工而崩溃。然后你还有各种——玛格丽特·撒切尔执政头几年出现的普遍危机感，失业率飙升等等。在这些情况下，威斯敏斯特发生的事情非常明显是更大经济问题的反射。
And you're more the latter, aren't you? I'm more the latter, yeah. And the crisis when I think about the 1970s, for example, I mean, there were some horrendous crises in the 1970s. I guess the two really classic ones are the winter of 73, 74 with the three-day week, all these states of emergency and the implosion of Ted Heath's premiership after the oil crisis. Then I suppose the winter of discontent in 78, 79, when James Callaghan's prime ministership pretty much collapsed because of the colossal breakdown of the relationship between the government and the trade unions and massive strikes. And then you've got the various sort of, there was a generalized sense of crisis under Margaret Thatcher the first couple of years with unemployment going through the roof and so on. In those cases, what was happening at Westminster was very clearly a reflection of bigger economic issues.
你知道的，所以并不是政治本身崩溃了。你可以争辩说，政治本身其实挺正常的，但政客们只是在艰难应对那些看似不可克服的问题，并被这些问题击垮了。而在这次事件中，我认为政治似乎存在某种奇特而腐烂的东西。部分原因在于，我认为他们开放了——由党内基层党员来选择党魁的选择权。这太糟糕了。哦，这是一个极其糟糕的错误。基本上就是保守党版的杰里米·科尔宾。完全正确，完全正确，是的。这正是我要说的。我会说，那是工党开始做的事情。这是在20世纪80年代由工党左翼推动的，托尼·本恩（Tony Benn）的伟大运动。他声称这将开放党内民主，
You know, so it wasn't that politics itself was broken. Politics itself, you could argue, was actually fine, but politicians were just struggling to deal with insuperable, appeared insuperable problems, and they were broken by them. In this case, I think there's seems to be something peculiarly rotten with politics part of that by the way is i think they have the opening up um the choice to party activists it's terrible oh it's a terrible terrible mistake basically the jeremy corbyn of the tories exactly exactly right yeah this is exactly what i'd say i would say that um that's the labour party started doing that it was driven by the left of the labor party in the 1980s tony ben it was his great campaign he claimed it would open up party democracy
允许普通党员而不是少数议员来选择党魁。而保守党觉得他们在90年代也不得不效仿。威廉·黑格改变了规则。所以从那时起，基层积极分子以及不同的——当然，与此相伴随的，是两党作为真正的大众党员组织本身的崩盘。尽管杰里米·科尔宾的支持者会正确地辩称，他是带着巨大的热情高潮被推上党魁之位的。而且实际上，在工党领导下，党内党员人数确实上升了。但这是一种不同类型的党员，与工党作为一个真正意义上的（打着引号的）全国性政党的时代不同。
allow ordinary members to choose the leader instead of a handful of mps um and the tourists felt they had to follow suit in the 1990s william haig changed the rules so since then the activists and and the different and of course what that went hand in hand with is the is the collapse of both parties as as proper mass membership organizations although jeremy corbyn supporters would argue that and correctly that that that he was born to the leadership on a great wave of enthusiasm. And actually the party membership under Labour went up. But that's a different kind of party membership from the days in which Labour was a genuinely, in inverted commas, national party.
那更像是一个长在腋下的淋巴结。一种突发的肿胀。嗯，杰里米·科尔宾执政时期发生的事情是，基本上，那些有着非常鲜明左翼原则的人涌入工党加入其中，因此将重心的中心极大地拉向了左翼。但工党最初在20世纪初刚刚成立时，在某些方面其实并不是一个极其左翼的政党。有成千上万的工人阶级党员，他们从来不把自己视为左翼。所以他们可能会使用社会主义的语言，
That was more like a kind of bubo under the armpit. A sudden swelling well what happened under jeremy corbyn was that basically people who had who had very marked left-wing principles rushed into the labour party to join it and therefore swung the center of gravity massively to the left but the labour party originally when it was a you know in the first years of the 20th century, was actually in some ways not actually an immensely left-wing party. There were tons and tons of working class members who would never have perceived themselves as being left-wing. So they might have used the language of socialism,
但比方说，他们依然非常爱国，在本质上是小c保守的。科尔宾时期的党员可不是这样。好吧，所以我们讨论过——我们讨论过很多次，工党是——所有政党都是联盟。工党基本上一直是工人阶级劳动者之间的联盟——所以才叫这个名字，是的，是的。正如奥威尔所说的那样——你最喜欢的名言，是的，喝西梅汁、穿凉鞋的人。而科尔宾——科尔宾的当选，真的是西梅汁饮用者（译者注：指中产阶级知识分子左翼）的胜利，战胜了——压倒了其他所有人。
but they were still, for example, very patriotic, very small-c conservative in there. That's not the case with the sort of Corbyn membership. Well, so we've we've talked so we've talked about this a lot that i mean it's the labour party is is we all parties are coalitions and the labour party has always been basically a coalition between working class labourers so hence the name yes yes and as all well would put it your favourite quote yes the prune juice drinking sandal wearers yes and corbin was
但同样地，保守党也是如此——我的意思是，这个名字本身就存在内在的紧张关系，保守党嘛，他们实际上并不怎么热衷于“保守”事物。所以这种紧张关系在于：你是要维护那种传统的、你知道的——保守党所热衷的所有传统事物呢，还是采取一种激进的自由主义路线？这正是特拉斯想要做的。是的，这基本上包括——你知道的——为了促进GDP增长而摧毁所有环境管制，砸烂一切你能砸烂的东西。汤姆，那个贵族爵位——那个爵位正在消失。是的，呃……我的意思是，在这两种情况下，
really corbin's election was the triumph of the the prune juice drinkers of the latter yeah over yeah everywhere but like like similarly the the tories i mean there's an inherent tension within the very name i mean then the conservative party yeah that they don't they're not actually very keen on conserving things so the tension is between do you uphold the kind of the traditional you know i don't know all the traditional stuff that conservatives are into um or do you adopt a kind of radical libertarian process which is what trust wanted to do yes which basically involves kind of you know destroying all environmental controls and um trashing everything you can in the cause of boosting gdp tom that peerage is that peerage is vanishing yeah um i mean in both cases there that there is a kind of
两党内部都存在着一个意识形态高度一致、动机极强的少数派。而且看起来，如果这两派人夺取了整个政党的控制权，结果似乎总是以眼泪收场。当然会这样，因为按定义，他们不仅不代表英国公众的大多数，甚至不代表他们自己的选民，不代表下一次大选中需要投票给他们的那，比如说，1300万人的大多数。嗯，或者实际上也不代表议员。或者议员，甚至不代表他们自己的议员。但支持允许议员而不是党内积极分子来投票选出领袖的强有力论点是，
very motivated ideologically coherent minority within both parties. And it does seem that in both cases, if they seize control of the entire party, it always seems to end in tears. Of course it does, because they're by definition, they're not representative, not merely of the mass of the British public, they're not even representative of their own voters, of their own mass of the, let's say, 13 million people who they need to vote for them at the next election. Well, or indeed MPs. Or MPs, or even their MPs. But the Birkin argument for allowing MPs rather than party activists to vote for leaders
议员是选出他们的选民的声音。是的。顺便说一句，这也是迈克尔·富特（Michael Foot）的观点。所以迈克尔·富特，20世纪80年代左翼工党领袖——他非常崇拜埃德蒙·伯克（Edmund Burke）——他过去常对本恩派的人说：“我们不仅仅是代表（delegates）。我们不仅仅是在等待别人告诉我们该怎么做，我们来到这里——”我的意思是，迈克尔·富特是埃德蒙·伯克的崇拜者。他说：“我们来到这里是为了运用我们的判断力，你们应该信任议员来选择他们想要的领袖。”这深深植根于英国议会制系统中，但20世纪80年代和90年代的改革将权力交给了小群体的积极分子，他们基本上选出了议员们并不想要的领袖。而这些人按定义就无法代表英国广大普通民众，他们中的大多数人其实并不怎么关心政治。所以回到那个问题：这仅仅是
is that MPs are the voice of the constituents who elect them. Yeah. Well, this is also, by the way, it was also Michael Foote's argument. So Michael Foote, the left-wing Labour Party leader of the 1980s, loved Michael Foote. He used to sort of say to the Benites, we're not just delegates. We're not just waiting to be told how to, we have come here. I mean, Michael Foote was a great admirer of Edmund Burke. He said, we have come here to use use our judgment and you should trust MPs to choose the leader that they want. Now that's deeply embedded in the British parliamentary system, but the reforms of the 1980s and 1990s handed power to small groups of activists who basically chose leaders that the MPs did not want. And who by definition are unrepresentative of the vast mass of the British people, most of whom do not care particularly about politics. So to come back to that question, is this only of
那些看《Newsnight》的人才感兴趣的事，还是它真的重要并产生影响？嗯，它很重要，我认为原因有二。第一，这反映了英国陷入的巨大困境。倒不是说脱欧本身——我知道我们的听众中有支持和反对脱欧两派的人，所以我认为不是脱欧本身的问题，而是“没有计划的脱欧”。我认为这才是真正的转折点。所以这不一定是离开欧盟——顺便说一句，如果人们觉得我们对某个方向有极大的偏见的话，我当时投的是留欧。无论如何，我不认为问题在于此，而在于绝对缺乏关于英国究竟将走向何方的战略或战略愿景。
interest to people who watch Newsnight or does it actually matter and does it impact? Well, it matters, I think, for two reasons. One, it's a reflection of the enormous hole that britain got itself into not so much with brexit i know we will have listeners who are on both sides of the brexit issue so i don't think it's brexit per se but i think it's brexit without a plan i think that was the real turning point so it's not necessarily i think leaving the european union i voted remain by the way in case people are thinking well i'm sure people who with very strong views will think we're terribly biased one way the other anyway but i don't think that was the issue so much as with an absolute absence of strategy or a strategic vision about where exactly britain
所以你会从不同的脱欧派竞选者那里听到完全不同的话。这意味着，一旦脱欧公投通过，就会产生持续的不确定性和派系内战，争论接下来到底该做什么。而特拉斯——但是——但多米尼克，只是——稍微唱一下反调，实际上是不是有两个计划？我的意思是，关于如何处理脱欧，其实一直有两个计划：一个是红色的保守党“平准化”（levelling up）、减少移民之类的那一套；另一个是“泰晤士河畔的新加坡”，废除规则手册、如果能促进GDP增长就往里排污水，诸如此类的事情。基本上，第一套计划在鲍里斯手里没行得通。所以他们想，好吧，让我们试试另一套。那可能会管用。他们对利兹·特拉斯尝试了这套，结果也没行得通。
would go so you would hear completely different things from different leave campaigners and what that meant is that as soon as the the referendum sort of passed there is a constant uncertainty and a factional civil war about exactly what to do next and and the trust well but but dominic just just yeah slightly played devil's advocate on that haven't there in fact been two plans i mean there have always been two plans about what to do with brexit and one is um a kind of red tory leveling up yes cut immigration um all that kind of stuff and the other one is singapore on the thames yes up the the rule book, pump sewage if it boosts GDP, all that kind of thing. And basically, the first one didn't work with Boris. And so they thought, well, let's try the other one. That might work. And they've tried it with the Liz Trust, and that hasn't worked
嗯，我认为这实际上就是所发生的事情。话虽如此，汤姆，我不认为人们像你所建议的那样把事情想得那么清楚。我不认为人们曾想过：“哦，那一套没行得通。”我认为这一切都与个性政治和宫廷政治混在了一起。而且，公平对政府而言——哦，他们接手了一个烂摊子。新冠疫情，然后是乌克兰。新冠疫情和乌克兰，当然。
either. Well, I think that's effectively what has happened. But that said, Tom, I don't think people thought it through as clearly as actually you've suggested. I don't think people did think, well, that hasn't worked. I think it became all messed up with personality politics and kind of court politics. But also, to be fair to the government, I mean, there's also... Oh, they've got a horrible inheritance. Yeah. COVID and then Ukraine. COVID and Ukraine, of course.
或者是。嗯，我认为这实际上就是所发生的事情.不过话又说回来，汤姆，我不认为人们像你所说的那样把问题想得那么清楚.我不认为人们真的在想，嗯，这行不通.我认为这完全被搞得一团糟，夹杂了个人政治和某种宫廷政治.但话又说回来，为了对政府公平起见，我的意思是，还有……哦，他们接手了一个烂摊子.是的.新冠疫情，然后是乌克兰.当然还有新冠和乌克兰.
That's torpedoed everything. So it's impossible for any minister to go on the radio and not say wow it's a global crisis i mean actually liz trust when she resigned i mean she got putin i think in after about 10 seconds didn't she she did it was a sentence too i think yeah and and she's not wrong it is a global crisis but we but we've we've handled it worst would you say that's fair? At a purely sort of high political level, we've certainly handled it worse.
这把一切都给彻底毁了。所以任何大臣上电台都不可避免地会说，天哪，这是一场全球危机。我的意思是，事实上，莉兹·特拉斯辞职时，我记得她在大约十秒钟后就把普京给扯进来了，不是吗？确实如此，而且我觉得也就用了一句话，没错。而且她说得没错，这确实是一场全球危机，但我们……但我们的处理方式是最糟糕的，你会觉得这样说公平吗？从纯粹的高层政治层面来看，我们的处理方式确实是最糟糕的。
I mean, it's easy to forget that, for example, our COVID furlough scheme was probably the most generous in Europe. Our vaccine rollout was very fast. We have actually come up with the weapons and stuff for Ukraine. So there are some things that we've done well, but in terms of the personalities of our politicians, the way they presented themselves, their standards of behavior and decency and so on, pay me to say that because you know, Tom. You are a patriot. That nobody loves to bash our continental neighbours as much as I do and, you know, to big up Britain.
我的意思是，人们很容易忘记，比如说，我们的新冠休假计划可能是全欧洲最慷慨的。我们的疫苗推广非常快。我们确实为乌克兰提供了武器等等。所以有些事情我们做得很好，但在我们政客的个性、他们的表现方式、他们的行为标准和体面等等方面，你付钱让我这么说吧，因为你知道的，汤姆。你是个爱国者。没有人像我一样喜欢痛骂我们的欧洲大陆邻居，并且，你知道的，大力吹捧英国。
But it's true, you know, last night. But in a way we are bigging up Britain. We're saying our crisis is the worst. If we can't be the best, let's be the worst. I mean, I think we should, we expect, I expect a rambustious democracy. I do not want a sort of European parliament style, people, children are doing interpretive dance in the aisles. Yes, we said this about, in the previous episode we did
但这是事实，你知道的，就在昨晚。但从某种意义上说，我们是在吹捧英国。我们在说我们的危机是最严重的。如果我们做不了最好，那就做最差吧。我的意思是，我觉得我们应该、我们期待、我期待一个充满生气的民主制度。我不希望那种欧洲议会风格的场面——人们、孩子们在走廊里跳现代舞。是的，我们在上一期节目里说过这个，在我们录制关于
on the resignation of Johnson, we did say that. But there's rambustious and then there's ludicrous yeah i mean bloodstained shambles yes and i think the element about shambles so to go back to your point about um does it matter to ordinary people it obviously matters enormously if it's going to put two percentage points on the interest rate that you pay for your mortgage. And this is the real thing with the trust fiasco, is that it's not just that we had an absolutely ludicrously ill-equipped person as prime minister for 45 days or whatever. It's that the implosion of her ridiculous economic plan, ill-conceived economic plan, meant that the bank of england will
约翰逊辞职的那期节目时，我们确实这么说过。但生机勃勃是一回事，荒谬绝伦又是另一回事，对吧？我的意思是，血腥的一团糟，是的。而且我觉得关于“一团糟”这一点——回到你刚才关于“它对普通人重要吗”的观点——如果这会给你的房贷利率加上两个百分点，那它显然极其重要。特拉斯这场闹剧真正的问题在于，不仅仅是因为我们在45天左右的时间里，让一个绝对荒谬地不称职的人当了首相；而是她那荒谬的经济计划、那个考虑不周的经济计划的崩溃，导致英格兰银行
probably end up raising interest rates a percentage point or two higher than they might otherwise have done and for some families that will be economically catastrophic and businesses and businesses exactly so that you know it's easy for us to sort of chuckle and just, you know, draw our comparisons. And it's easy for political correspondents, of course, to get very excited about all the hullabaloo and the sort of hurly-burly. But it's important to remember these are real, these economic figures really matter to people. So, yes, I think it does matter. What I really hope it doesn't do is it lead to a sort of long-term 70s style culture of sort of negativity and all that. Not just here, but among people, do they invest in Britain? Is Britain a bit of a dead duck? All that kind of thing.
最终可能会把利率比原本预期的水平再提高一两个百分点，对某些家庭来说，这将是一场经济灾难，对企业也是如此，对企业而言正是如此。所以，你知道的，我们很容易轻描淡写地笑笑，然后，你知道的，做点对比。政治记者们当然也很容易对所有的喧嚣和忙乱感到非常兴奋。但重要的是要记住，这些都是真实的，这些经济数据对人们来说真的非常重要。所以，是的，我确实认为这很重要。我真正希望的是，它不要导致那种长期的70年代风格的消极文化和所有这一切。不仅在这里，而且在人们中间，他们还会投资英国吗？英国是不是有点像一只死鸭子？诸如此类的事情。
But reading your books on the 70s, the sense of crisis there seemed to be that the massive indicators in the economy, so inflation, unemployment, growth, were consistently against the government. It didn't matter whether it was Tory or Labour. It was a kind of a disaster. And perhaps in a similar way, was bred of of foreign circumstances and national incompetence yes and do you think that we're back in a kind of similar similar bind to that is this a return to the 70s as people say or or is it worse is it worse or is it better oh it's worse was it better uh because i suppose one of the things in the 70s is that you had North Sea oil starting to come on. You did come in.
但读了你关于70年代的书后，那里的危机感似乎在于，经济上的宏观指标——比如通货膨胀、失业率、经济增长——持续与政府作对。无论是保守党还是工党执政都一样。这简直是一场灾难。也许以类似的方式，这是由外部环境和国家无能孕育出来的。是的，你认为我们又陷入了那种类似困境吗？这正如人们所说的是70年代的回归，还是说……或者情况更糟糕？是更糟糕还是更好？哦，比那时更糟，还是更好？呃，因为我想70年代的一个情况是，北海石油开始开采了。石油确实进来了。
So that's a boon. And I guess the demographics were also more positive. Britain was a younger nation then. Yes. But on the counter argument to that, Tom, I suppose would be that the real, stepping right back, the real problem for Britain in the 70s was that it was embark about to embark on a very long delayed and very painful period of economic transition which you could argue in the really long run is the transition from basically the victorian or the immediately post-victorian economy to the economy we have now and that that was going to have to come it was going to be so difficult
所以这是一件好事。而且我猜当时的人口统计数据也更积极。英国在当时是个更年轻的国家。是的。但与之相反的论点是，汤姆，我想会是这样：把视线拉远来看，英国在70年代真正的、面临的真正问题是，它正要开始一段非常漫长且非常痛苦的经济转型期。你可以认为，从长远来看，这基本上是从维多利亚时代或紧随维多利亚时代的经济向我们现在拥有的经济的转变，而这是不可避免的，将会非常困难，
it was going to involve a lot of lost jobs, a lot of damage to communities and so on. And that that was the problem that lay under everything else. Failing industries, steel, coal, shipbuilding, all these kinds of things. These things that were clearly just going to go. And so when people looked at britain from outside they kind of said it's an old country and one that is desperately desperately crying out for modernization
它将涉及大量的工作岗位流失、对社区的巨大破坏等等。这就是隐藏在所有其他问题之下的根本问题。行将没落的产业，钢铁、煤炭、造船，所有这些。这些显然注定要消失的行业。所以当外界看着英国时，他们会觉得这是一个老去的国家，一个迫切、迫切渴望现代化的国家。
um britain undoubtedly has issues and challenges right now as so many countries do but i don't think it's an outlier perhaps in quite the same way i think i suppose what some listeners would probably say wouldn't they is that they think brexit uh represents a different kind of existential challenge yeah maybe but i think looking at it in the the international context and i think back to the episodes on oil that we did with helen thompson yes where she talked about how essentially the moment that the global economy became centered on oil rather than on coal, this was a problem, not just for Britain, but for the whole of Europe, that essentially it is more expensive for Europeans to make things because our energy
嗯，英国现在无疑有它的问题和挑战，就像许多国家一样，但我不认为它是一个特例，至少不是以那种完全相同的方式。我想，一些听众可能会这么说吧？他们会认为脱欧代表了一种不同类型的存在主义挑战。是的，也许吧。但如果我们从国际背景来看，我想起我们和海伦·汤普森一起制作的关于石油的节目，是的，她在节目中谈到，基本上，当全球经济的中心从煤炭转向石油的那一刻起，这就成了一个问题，不仅对英国，对全欧洲都是如此。基本上，欧洲人制造东西的成本更高，因为我们的能源
is more expensive than it was for Russia or for the United States. And we're definitely back in that situation now. Is there a risk, not just for Britain, but for the whole of Europe, that we're going to go through a process of de-industrialization bred by the brute fact that we have less cheap energy than, say, the Americans do? Crikey, Tom, I thought I'd come here to, you know, exchange a few cheap quips about Liz Truss. Yes, I suppose in the long run that is the fear, isn't it? That there's a further period of, is it de-industrialization? I don't know, a further period of economic transition to come
比俄罗斯或美国的能源更贵。我们现在绝对又回到了那种境地。不仅对英国，对整个欧洲来说，是否存在这样一种风险：我们将经历一个去工业化的过程，而这正是由我们拥有的廉价能源比美国人少这一残酷事实所孕育的？天哪，汤姆，我还以为我是来这里……你知道的，交流几句关于莉兹·特拉斯的俏皮话呢。是的，我想从长远来看，这就是人们所担忧的，不是吗？还会有一段……是去工业化吗？我不知道，未来还会有另一段经济转型期，
in which Europe will be even more, Western Europe will be even more, be on the receiving end of globalization, as it were, than it was in the 1970s and 1980s. And that, yes, communities in Britain, which have perhaps become very dependent on foreign investment or on cheap manufacturing abroad or whatever it might be, are going to face some pretty tough winters with energy becoming more expensive and with this sort of period of change. Then are you going to
在此期间，西欧受全球化的冲击将比20世纪70和80年代时更深、更彻底。而且，是的，英国的社区——这些社区可能已经变得非常依赖外国投资、或者依赖海外的廉价制造业等等——将面临一些相当严峻的冬天，因为能源变得更加昂贵，而且伴随着这种变革时期。那么你将会
see prime ministers rising and falling more and more quickly in your third century Rome style? Yes, exactly. And perhaps not just in Britain, that crises may start to manifest themselves in other European countries as well. Well, I mean, the United States might be a good parallel here. You have, you saw... But the United States is in a good position because it's energy rich. It is.
看到首相们在你那第三世纪罗马风格的政治轮回中以越来越快的速度起起落落吗？是的，完全如此。而且可能不仅在英国，危机也可能开始在其他欧洲国家显现。嗯，我的意思是，美国在这里可能是一个很好的对照。你看到了……但美国处于有利地位，因为它能源丰富。确实如此。
Its energy is cheap. Ours is prohibitively expensive. But the politics of grievance and resentment has become much more marked today in America than it was in, let us say, the 1980s and 1990s. So in other words, there are large communities of people who feel left behind. And that is obviously one of the key drivers of modern politics. People who feel locked out, excluded, they feel they've been cheated of something.
它的能源很便宜。我们的能源贵得离谱。但在今天的美国，满腹牢骚和怨恨的政治氛围变得比20世纪80年代和90年代时要明显得多。换句话说，有大量群体觉得自己被时代抛弃了。这显然是现代政治的关键驱动力之一。那些觉得自己被锁在门外、被排挤的人，他们觉得自己被剥夺了什么。
I mean, this might be in a Rust Belt community in the Midwest, or it might be in a town in the so-called Red Wall in Britain, or it might be in, you know, eastern France among Le Pen voters, you know, or, you know, anywhere in Europe, effectively. And that could, there was an excellent chance that that will become a greater and greater part of the political landscape. And that is conventionally how we like to think of it,
我的意思是，这可能发生在铁锈带的中西部社区，或者英国所谓的“红墙”选区的一个城镇，或者可能是，你知道的，法国东部勒庞的选民当中，你知道的，或者欧洲的任何地方，实际上都是如此。而且，这极有可能成为政治版图中越来越大的一部分。而我们通常习惯的看法是，
that all the West is in it together, that what happens in America is basically reflected in Europe. But isn't there a possibility, which has seemed to me the implication of those episodes we we did with helen and that has kind of basically haunted me ever since and nothing that has happened since we recorded those episodes has persuaded me to change my view on this that america and europe may be going on radically divergent parabolas that that if you have cheap energy in the 20th century and into the 21st century, then your economy
西方命运与共，美国发生的事基本上会在欧洲得到反映。但难道没有这样一种可能性吗？这似乎正是我们和海伦录制的那些节目所暗示的，并且基本上从那以后一直萦绕在我心头，而且自从我们录完那些节目以来，发生的一切都没有动摇我对这一看法的改变：美国和欧共体可能会走上截然不同的发展轨迹。如果在20世纪和21世纪你拥有廉价能源，那么你的经济
will grow. If you don't, it will decline. And isn't the possibility that what we're going through at the moment with Putin and cutting of the Nord Stream and all that kind of stuff, that actually trust perhaps was justified in mentioning him as early as she did, that Europe stands on the cusp of a process of, of de-industrialization. I mean,
就会增长。如果没有，它就会衰退。难道没有这样一种可能性吗：我们目前正在经历的普京切断“北溪”管道以及所有这些事情，实际上特拉斯这么早就提到他可能是情有可原的？欧洲正处于一个去工业化过程的边缘。我的意思是，
I agree. This was meant to be a cheery and jolly episode with, you know, some light quips about Roman emperors, but I. You decided to go, go in. Isn't that the joy of a podcast that you.
我同意。这本该是一期轻松愉快的节目，有一些关于罗马皇帝的轻松俏皮话，但我……你决定单刀直入、大谈特谈了。这难道不是播客的乐趣吗？
As soon as your peerage, as soon as the peerage went up in smoke, you just became incredibly morbid and gloomy. Well, I don't know the answer to this. I think listeners, if they listen back, will notice that's the moment when their tone changes. Yeah, I'm sure
你一拿到贵族爵位……一听到贵族爵位化为泡影，你就变得无比病态和阴郁。好吧，我不知道答案是什么。我想听众如果回听的话，会注意到那就是他们语气转变的时刻。是的，我敢肯定
you're right, Tom. I think you probably are right. I think it is a sort of distressing thought that actually, because Europe doesn't have all these cheap energy sources, that Europe is going to find it increasingly difficult. I mean, whether that means a complete divergence of, you know, strategically from the United States or whatever, I don't know. But you're absolutely right that I don't think if you were, you know,
你说得对，汤姆。我想你大概说得对。我认为这是一个令人沮丧的想法：事实上，由于欧洲没有所有这些廉价能源，欧洲将发现日子越来越难过。我的意思是，这是否意味着在战略上与美国彻底分道扬镳什么的，我不知道。但你绝对说得对，我不认为如果你……
if you're starting to play a strategy board game set in the year 2022, and then moving onwards, do you choose to play as Western Europe? No, you probably don't, do you? No. Well,
如果你开始玩一个以2022年为背景并向后推演的战略棋盘游戏，你会选择扮演西欧吗？不，你大概不会，对吧？不。好吧，
I, and I thought it was kind of symbolic that the parliamentary vote yesterday that I was, I wasn't actually, I was off batting for Alfred the Great in a Greatest British King debate. Yeah, how did you get on? I came second behind Elizabeth I. I was doing that for Dan Snow.
而且我以为昨天的议会投票很有象征意义，当时我……其实我不在，我去为阿尔弗雷德大帝在一个“最伟大的英国国王”辩论赛中摇旗呐喊了。是的，你表现得怎么样？我在伊丽莎白一世之后得了第二名。我是为丹·斯诺做这件事的。
So at least one Liz ends the week triumphant. Yes. But as I gather, this was all about a vote on fracking, which has been banned for environmental reasons and Liz Truss wanted to reintroduce, wants to reintroduce. Yeah. An incredibly toxic policy with much of the Tory party, it has to be said.
所以至少还有一个“利兹”以胜利结束这一周。是的。但据我所知，这全关乎一项关于水力压裂法的投票。该技术因环保原因被禁，而莉兹·特拉斯想要重新引入，想要重新引入。是的。对于保守党的大多数人来说，这是一个极其棘手的政策，必须得承认。
Exactly. So symbolic, perhaps, of the struggle to get cheap energy that is kind of, I guess, weighing down. Anyway, I'm sorry. One other thing we haven't mentioned, Tom. No, no, no, it's fine. One other thing we haven't mentioned at all. I, no, no, it's fine. One other thing we haven't mentioned at all, I'll ask you, because otherwise it's just you interrogating me
没错。所以这或许象征着争取廉价能源的艰难斗争，我猜，这正压得人喘不过气来。总之，我很抱歉。还有一件事我们没提到，汤姆。不，不，不，没关系。还有一件事我们完全没提到。我来问你，否则就变成你对我的严刑拷问了，
about increasingly bleak existential questions, is whether the standard of politicians has declined, as people so often argue that it has. Do you think they've declined in our lifetime? I always feel that. So I now look back on the days of good King Boris. What wouldn't we give for his moral probity and the stability that he... Yes, but I wonder whether that isn't just the fact that, to me, the politicians of my childhood seem colossal figures. But I mean that almost literally.
追问那些日益黯淡的存在主义问题：政客的水平是否像人们经常争论的那样下降了？你认为在我们有生之年他们的水平下降了吗？我总是有这种感觉。所以我现在回想起好国王鲍里斯的日子。我们愿意付出什么来换取他那高尚的道德操守以及他带来的稳定……是的，但我怀疑这是否只是因为，在我看来，我童年时期的政客似乎是些高大伟岸的人物。我的意思是字面意义上的。
I'm a small child watching them on a television. They seem physically bigger. Whereas now, politicians are now younger than me, so I'm less respectful of them. The politicians of our childhoods often had come to politics later in life. They had, I mean, in our case, a lot of them had served in the Second World War. So someone like Dennis Healy, Labour Chancellor in the 1970s. I mean, a Labour Chancellor who has to go to the International Monetary Fund to beg for a bailout. But he had been a beach master at the land allied landings and anzio
我当时是个看电视的小不点。他们看起来体型更高大。而现在，政客们比我还年轻，所以我对他们的敬意就没那么多了。我们童年时代的政客往往是在人生晚年才涉足政治的。我的意思是，就我们而言，他们当中许多人曾在第二次世界大战中服役。所以就像丹尼斯·希利，20世纪70年代的工党财政大臣。我的意思是，一个不得不去国际货币基金组织乞求财政援助的工党财政大臣。但他曾是盟军在安齐奥登陆时的海滩主管
so basically organizing stuff on the beaches i mean an incredibly dangerous and complicated job but that's a different matter isn't it that you know hinterland was dennis healy's great word uh yes and always about himself great deal i mean they uh you know a kind of interesting backstory isn't necessary to be a good policy i I mean, Tony Blair didn't have a particularly interesting backstory, but I think he was a very, very effective prime minister. Everybody knows you love Tony Blair. John Major did have an interesting backstory, which he then tried to make as boring as possible.
也就是基本上负责海滩上的调度工作，我的意思是，这是一项极其危险和复杂的工作，但那是另一回事了，不是吗？你知道的，人生阅历（hinterland）是丹尼斯·希利最喜欢用的词，呃，是的，而且总是关于他自己的事，非常多。我的意思是，他们……你知道的，有趣的背景并不一定是成为好政客的必要条件。我的意思是，托尼·布莱尔并没有特别有趣的背景，但我认为他是一位非常、非常高效的首相。大家都知道你喜欢托尼·布莱尔。约翰·梅杰确实有一个有趣的背景，而他后来试图把它变得尽可能无聊。
Well, actually, John Major wrote, because John Major, his father had sold garden gnomes. That's great, isn't it? He's meant to be the model for major tom isn't he and the bowie song yeah i mean our producer dom is sending us a message the only person to run away from the circus to become an accountant uh so his father who had been a music hall performer um john major later wrote a book about the history of the music hall and which i reviewed it's good wasn't it and the preface yeah there's a wonderful scene in the preface where he says basically he went to visit
嗯，事实上，约翰·梅杰写过……因为约翰·梅杰的父亲曾卖过花园小矮人雕像。这太棒了，不是吗？他本该是鲍伊歌曲中“梅杰汤姆”的原型，对吧？嗯，我们的制作人多姆给我们发了一条消息：他是唯一一个从马戏团跑出来当会计的人。所以他的父亲曾是一名音乐厅艺人，嗯，约翰·梅杰后来写了一本关于音乐厅历史的书，我还写过书评呢。写得很好，不是吗？还有前言……前言里有一个精彩的场景，他说基本上他去探望
his father when he was his father was dying and he was he lived upstairs in some sort of boarding house or something very kind of sort of shabby post-war london kind of scene in brixton john major yeah and john major goes up to visit him and he said a succession of very strange, moth-eaten, decrepit people would come up and down the stairs. And these were other ancient musical performers visiting his father. So anyway, yes, that's a tangent. I think they have declined. But I also think the environment in which we expect them to perform has become degraded by social media by rolling news by all these kinds of
他的父亲，当时他父亲快不行了，他住在某种公寓的楼上，或是布里克斯顿那种非常破旧的战后伦敦布景里的某种地方，约翰·梅杰，是的。约翰·梅杰上楼去探望他，他说一连串非常奇怪、被蛀虫咬过、衰老破败的人上下走动。这些人都是去探望他父亲的其他老音乐厅艺人。总之，是的，这是个题外话。我认为他们的水平确实下降了。但我也认为，我们期待他们表现的环境已经被社交媒体、滚动新闻以及所有这些事物所毁坏，
things which mean that they don't it's very hard for them to to be impressive actually you know they're expected to yeah you know that to live in this world of soundbites they're given so little time to write to think to read to take their time to change their minds but one of the things about about Liz Truss and Kwasi Kwarteng was that they kind of did, didn't they? They've written a book. Their book, Britannia Unchained. Well, you said, you wrote a great essay for Unheard,
这意味着他们做不到……实际上要让他们给人留下深刻印象非常难，你知道的，他们被期望去……是的，你知道的，生活在这个由简短引语构成的世界里，他们被给予如此少的时间去写作、去思考、去阅读、去从容不迫、去改变主意。但关于莉兹·特拉斯和夸西·夸滕的一点是，他们某种程度上确实做到了，不是吗？他们写过一本书。他们的书《绝望的布列塔尼亚》。嗯，你写过，你为Unherd网站写了一篇很棒的文章，
which UNHCRD, about Kwasi Kwarteng being the wrong kind of intelligent. Well, he's phenomenally clever. Yeah. There is absolutely no doubt about that i mean somebody i i said this in the article and somebody uh tweeted me and they said oh anyone could could have you know he just was lucky he was privileged that's not the case quasi-quartang had an absolutely astounding run of achievements from the clearly from the moment he entered school as a little boy until basically the moment he became an MP. He won endless medals and prizes. He won scholarships. He had a double first from Cambridge. He had a PhD. He wrote books. He was fantastically clever,
关于夸西·夸滕是“那种聪明得不是地方的人”。嗯，他聪明得惊人。是的。毫无疑问，我的意思是，我在文章中说过这一点，有人在推特上@我，他们说，哦，任何人都可以……他只是运气好，他有特权。事实并非如此，夸西·夸滕从他作为一个小男孩走进学校的那一刻起，直到他基本上成为国会议员的那一刻为止，经历了一系列令人惊叹的成就。他赢得过无数的奖章和奖项。他赢得了奖学金。他在剑桥拿到了双优等学位。他有博士学位。他写过书。他聪明绝顶，
but he was also clearly lacking in intellectual humility, because somebody with any intellectual humility would not have embarked on such a ludicrously over-excessively radical package of tax changes, which was clearly going to... Everybody had sort of warned him it would explode in your face, and it did. Capax imperi nisi imperaset. The famous lines written by Tacitus about the emperor galba that everyone would have said he was perfectly suited to be emperor until he actually became emperor and you could perhaps say the same about you could say about quasi-carting you'd never said
但他显然也缺乏知识上的谦逊，因为任何有点知识谦逊的人都不会着手推出如此荒谬、过度激进的税收变革方案，这显然会……每个人都某种程度上警告过他这会在你脸上爆炸，结果确实如此。Capax imperi nisi imperaset（人若未掌权，皆被视为具备执政之才）。塔西提斯关于加尔巴皇帝的名言，意思是每个人都会说他完全适合当皇帝，直到他真的当了皇帝。或许你可以对夸西·夸滕说同样的话，你永远不会对……
you'd never said about this trust no quasi-carting very impressive figure this trust always seemed faintly ludicrous faintly i mean i i i'll be frank tom i will be frank about uh when the when boris fell and there was the talk of it never occurred to me that she would succeed him because i just thought she's so obviously a terrible communicator yeah you know it's so incredibly unimpressive yeah and that is so important, isn't it? I mean, she's a flat, monotone voice. Nothing she ever says is of any interest. Yeah, I think it matters enormously. And it's a funny example.
你永远不会对莉兹·特拉斯这么说。夸西·夸滕是个非常令人印象深刻的人物，而莉兹·特拉斯总是显得有些荒谬，有些……我的意思是，坦白讲，汤姆，我将直言不讳地谈到鲍里斯倒台时，当时有传言说……我从未想过她会接替他，因为我只觉得她显然是个糟糕的沟通者，是的，你知道的，这太让人印象深刻了……不对，是太不令人印象深刻了。是的，这太重要了，不是吗？我的意思是，她的声音平淡、单调。她说过的任何话都没有吸引力。是的，我觉得这极其重要。这是一个有趣的例子。
This thing about we're talking about the activists choosing their leaders. It's a funny example of something that you see again and again in politics, which is that people who are really, really invested in politics are such bad judges of politics. And I often say to people, you know, the less you know about politics, the better able you are to judge it. But the weird thing was that she was elected almost because she lacked... So Rishi Sunak, who fought the leadership campaign with her, it was his smoothness and his plausibility that party members seem not to have liked.
我们谈到激进分子选择他们的领导人这件事，这是你在政治中一次又一次看到的有趣例子，那就是真正极度投入政治的人往往是极其糟糕的政治裁判。我经常对人们说，你知道的，你对政治了解得越少，你对它的判断力反而越好。但奇怪的是，她当选几乎是因为她缺乏……所以里希·苏纳克，那个和她竞选党魁的人，党员们似乎不喜欢他的圆滑和巧舌如簧。
Yeah. His metropolitan-ness, his wealth. But it's his fluency and his smoothness. And so I suppose the implication was that because she had neither fluency nor smoothness therefore she was somehow more authentic even though she had junked all her principles after after leaving university because she'd previously been a republican liberal democrat well she'd been a remainer and then she became, yeah, anyway. Anyway, Dominic, she is gone. She is gone. Yeah, I should give up. I should let her go.
是的，他的大都市气派、他的财富。但正是他的流畅和圆滑。所以我想这意味着，因为她既不流畅也不圆滑，所以她某种程度上更具真实感——尽管她在离开大学后抛弃了她所有的原则，因为她以前是个共和派自由民主党人。好吧，她曾是个留欧派，然后她变成了，是的，无论如何。总之，多米尼克，她已经下台了。她已经下台了。是的，我该放弃了。我应该放过她。
And I feel that we have lingered over the autopsy too long. Do you? Yeah, I do a bit, really. Oh, I think you can just let... Well, this is another peerage attempt, is it? No, I wouldn't want one from her. Yeah, because you'd be known when people would say lord holland and people would be muttering behind you yeah yeah i'm holding out for penny mordant to knight me on the deck of the golden hind or
我觉得我们在尸检上逗留得太久了。是吗？对，我确实觉得有点太久了。哦，我觉得你可以就……好吧，这又是想谋求贵族爵位了吗？不，我才不想从她那里拿呢。是的，因为那样当别人说“霍兰勋爵”时，人们会在你背后窃窃私语……对，对，我在等彭妮·莫道特在“金鹿号”甲板上册封我为爵士，
something like that well she's a naval she she is a naval reservist and of course she competed in splash the with tom tailey so so she would have very much enjoyed our trafalgar podcasts and if she becomes pm let's hope that i hope she listens to them again and does her duty it gives us both appearances okay exactly on that note of uh shameless 18th century would be cronyism, thanks very much for listening. Do not forget, if you are not Restless History members, today is Trafalgar Day, and you can mark this most glorious day in British history, Battle of Trafalgar, and wash the taste of the horrors of contemporary British politics out of your mouth by listening to our episode on the actual Battle of Trafalgar by joining up to the Restless History Club.
诸如此类的事情。好吧，她是海军……她是一名海军预备役军人，当然，她还和汤姆·塔利一起参加过《Splash!》跳水秀，所以她会非常喜欢我们的特拉法加海战播客。如果她当了首相，让我们希望……我希望她能再次收听这些播客，履行她的职责，给我们两个人都封个爵位。好吧，正是在这种无耻的18th世纪式裙带关系的基调下，非常感谢大家的收听。别忘了，如果你还不是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的会员，今天是特拉法加日，你可以纪念英国历史上这个最辉煌的日子——特拉法加战役，并通过加入“历史的其余部分”俱乐部来收听我们关于特拉法加战役本身的节目，从而洗刷掉当代英国政治恐怖给你留下的恶劣滋味。
If not, you'll have to wait till Monday. Yeah, and it's worth saying, Tom, earlier in the podcast, we may have suggested that giving power to activists and members was a bad idea. No, we're all in favour of Restless History Club. We're all for it. No, we're all in favour of the Rest is History Club. We're all for it. Yeah, we're all for it. All for it. All right.
如果不是会员，你就得等到周星期一了。是的，而且值得一提的是，汤姆，在播客的前面部分，我们可能暗示过把权力交给激进分子和党员是个坏主意。不，我们全都支持“历史的其余部分”俱乐部。我们全力支持。不，我们全都支持“历史的其余部分”俱乐部。我们全力支持。是的，我们全力支持。全力支持。好吧。
We'll see you probably next week for the next resignation. Yes. See you then. Bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
我们大概会在下周因下一场辞职而再次见面。是的。到时见。拜拜。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取额外单集、抢先收听、无广告收听
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。